你知道嗎
台灣有一種病
最燒錢
光是一年
就要燒掉
530億
健保費
有快10萬的人
天天都在燒錢
是哪一種病啊
就是慢性腎臟病
太誇張了吧
景氣差就算了
還要把你的錢
都洗進醫院去
不划算
怎麼樣來顧好你的腎
遠離腎臟病
馬上告訴你
胡乃文開講囉
我是你的老朋友 胡醫師
吃水果別亂吃
腎臟病吃一口恐喪命
腎臟不好的人注意聽喔
腎功能不好 洗腎
或腎臟病患者
不要吃
楊桃
連楊桃乾
楊桃汁也不要吃
有的人吃了可能就中毒
嚴重的話還會
死掉了
這5種人最危險
為了健康一口
都不要吃
1慢性腎臟病第三期以上的人
2急性腎臟病恢復期的人
3洗腎病人
4單側腎臟切除手術
還沒有滿六個月的人
5尿毒症的人
楊桃對腎臟不好嗎
為什麼會中毒
楊桃裡頭有一種神經毒素
叫做Caramboxin
身體健康的人
吃楊桃沒問題
但是腎功能差的人
吃了楊桃沒辦法代謝
毒素一直累積
就會直攻腦裡頭的神經
出現打嗝 嘔吐 抽搐
甚至於昏迷死亡
最可怕的是
沒有藥可以解這種毒
萬一腎不好的人
不小心吃到了
楊桃怎麼辦
立刻找醫生別拖了
像我們健康的人
也會擔心
楊桃一天可以吃幾顆呀
拜託了不要吃幾顆好不好
你一天吃三四片沒問題
但是吃一整顆就多了
更不建議
空腹
或者天天吃喔
因為楊桃它裡頭草酸多
草酸會影響鈣的吸收
而且草酸會跟鈣結合
成為草酸結石
甚至還會傷到你的骨頭
後面我會告訴你
腎臟病人的飲食禁忌
要看到最後喔
泡澡＋按腰後1穴
排毒逆轉腎
腎臟病最可怕的是
早期幾乎沒有症狀
有六成的人一檢查就晚期了
我臨床上看到的病人
腎功能受損比較嚴重
就會見到這幾種現象
一 身上有尿騷味
二 嘴唇黑
三 有口臭
四 舌頭暗紅
五 舌苔厚白髒的
慢性腎臟病
最愛找上這三種人
糖尿病 高血壓 痛風的人
洗腎的患者裡面糖友最多
所以一定要好好的控制
不然腎臟提早報銷
就大大麻煩了
腎臟不好的人怎麼改善
來 給你兩個
簡單的養腎法
你是健康的人
可以養腎預防腎臟病
有腎臟病的人
你就能夠
促進血液循環幫助排毒
第一個養腎法
按摩腎俞穴
能夠補腎益精
改善腎臟血液循環
腎俞穴在肚臍正後方
脊椎左右兩邊
大概兩指寬的寬度
你每天按摩它個3分鐘
補腎益精
促進血液循環
暖呼呼又舒服
第二個養腎法
就是泡澡
中醫看腎臟病
常把它當成水腫來治療
水腫分成兩種
腰以下
腰以上
金匱要略裡頭記載
在腰部以下的水腫
就要靠多排尿來治療
在腰以上的水腫
就要靠出汗來治療
泡澡就是最簡單的發汗方式
一位腎臟科醫生分享病例
有一位八十多歲的老太太
腎絲球過濾率只剩下16
按時吃藥以外
還搭配早晚泡澡15分鐘
三個月之後
腎絲球體濾過濾升到了40
血壓恢復正常
全身痠痛也改善了
是不是很棒
冬天泡澡很舒服
把身體裡的毒素
和重金屬等等出汗排出去
也是很好的護腎方法之一
人到一個年紀
油要挑
脾氣要收
接下來
進一段廣告
介紹一款很懂你的苦茶油
5個習慣再不改易拖垮腎
全世界洗腎人口最多的國家
你知道在哪裡嗎
跟你說就是我們台灣
洗腎有快十萬人
慢性腎臟病的人有270萬人
就是說每八個人裡頭
就有一個人腎臟不健康
實在很誇張
想避免洗腎
5個習慣先改一改
一 愛吃高油高鹽加工食品
二 蛋白質吃過量
三不愛喝水
四 亂吃止痛藥保健食品
五 高壓與熬夜
我們先講第一個
愛吃高油 高鹽加工食品
拉麵
泡麵
熱狗
火腿
這些食物吃起來
香噴噴對不對
常常吃你會得到血壓升高
腎臟血流變差
腎小管會比超商店員還要忙
每天都在超時加班
加班久了撐不住了
你可以怎麼做
多吃新鮮的原型的食物
高鹽食物加工食品
盡量是排去在外吧
太鹹的泡麵湯
還有拉麵湯
不要整碗都把它喝完
喝兩口滿足就好了
第二個蛋白質吃過量
減肥健身的人注意
蛋白質代謝
會產生很多的含氮的廢物
像氨之類的
都要靠腎臟來過濾排毒
長期的蛋白質吃過量
腎臟就會被你操壞了
一天要吃多少的蛋白質
才不會太多呢
有人建議說
成人每天的蛋白質量
大概抓個體重乘以0.8克就好了
吃太多
反而讓腎臟負擔太大了
第三個 不愛喝水
你上廁所的時候
看一下你的尿液
如果顏色比較偏黃
表示水喝得太少了
這樣一來就容易尿液太濃
結石 感染
都容易發生
不要以為水只能解渴
它能幫助你的
腎臟代謝毒素
像防腐劑 人工添加物等等
怎麼樣喝才對呢
少量 多次喝
白開水
才是最實際的養腎法
第四個
亂吃止痛藥 保健食品
前衛生署副署長李龍騰先生
曾經說過
全世界沒有健康食品
他自己根本不吃這些
他還指出
台灣和日本的
洗腎率居高不下
跟大家過度依賴健康食品
一定有大關係
因為健康食品
本質上
算是加工的食品
吃太多腎臟
也會拼命工作負擔超重
至於止痛藥
有些人腰痠背痛
就去藥房買貼布
或者是買止痛藥吃
我建議你
如果你是偶爾
腰痠背痛不舒服
使用貼布以後
沒有明顯的緩解
一定要趕緊找醫生
幫你看一看
第五個高壓和熬夜
晚睡熬夜的人啊
你是不是本來應該
從從容容 游刃有餘
的上床睡覺
現在卻是
匆匆忙忙 連滾帶爬
的上床
你看看有一位
蔡依林小姐
她過去幾乎天天熬夜
直到被皮蛇所纏身
就帶狀疱疹了
現在晚上九點半
乖乖的早早就去睡覺
健康找回來了
皮膚變得更是水噹噹
長期熬夜壓力大
血壓血糖容易失控
腎臟還得拼命為你加班
嘿 別等到腎臟報銷
才花大錢來治病
太傷你的荷包了
對不對啊
百天不吃一物
恢復腎臟健康
腎功能不好的人
我跟你說
第一件要注意的事就是
不要吃重鹹的
吃太鹹吃重鹹
會怎麼樣呢
讓腎臟過勞
身體的鹽份太高
腎臟就得要拼命
把它排出去
腎絲球腎小管都拼命工作
連帶的血壓也會升高
加速腎功能的惡化
甚至於提高腎臟病的風險
腎功能受損
真的能靠飲食來逆轉
二十多年前
我岳母被醫生
檢查出腎功能異常
我太太急著問我怎麼辦
我跟她說
把岳母的飲食調整一下
我說一百天不要加鹽
不要加醬
結果呢
我岳母真的在一百天之後
腎功能恢復正常喔
醫宗金鑑
雜病心法要訣裡頭
有這麼一句話
他說若能戒鹽醬
淡食百日 多有生者
什麼意思啊
就是戒鹽戒醬
大概一百天還有很多人
都可以繼續存活
就這個意思
慢性腎臟病的人
不妨你明天就開始來試試看
腎功能健康的人
用這兩招保護腎臟
第一 醬料分開放
第二 用天然食材當香料
你在點餐的時候
跟店員說
醬料少一點
或者是醬料分開放
這樣子你可以自己決定
我要沾的份量是多少
二 用天然食材當香料
喜歡自己料理的人
建議你少用雞湯塊
改用天然食材
洋蔥 蒜頭 香菇
當湯底
炒菜可以用
九層塔 薑 蔥 蒜 胡椒
來代替化學調料品
這樣腎臟保養好了
吃起來身體也更舒服
腎臟病人怎麼吃
3水果5蔬菜放心吃
腎臟病人最關心的就是
到底什麼能吃什麼不能吃
從中醫古籍戒鹽醬的理論
我們可以延伸出來
腎臟病人要避免吃
吃味道濃重 過鹹 過辣 過酸 過甜
等等所謂的
厚味的食物
這些食物容易
增加腎臟的負擔
讓腎功能惡化的更快
有3種食物
建議腎臟病人少吃或不吃
一 加工肉品 肉鬆 香腸 培根
二 加工食品 泡麵 洋芋片 蜜餞
三 醃漬食品 泡菜 醬瓜 榨菜
那麼腎臟病人
在蔬果上有哪些禁忌
腎臟病人可以吃的蔬菜有哪些
高麗菜 花椰菜 豆芽菜 絲瓜 茭白筍
腎臟病人可以吃的水果有哪些
芭樂 蘋果 還有 藍莓
腎臟病人需要限制的蔬菜就是
菠菜 地瓜葉 馬鈴薯 番茄
它們都是因為鉀太高了
需要少吃或汆燙
去掉那個鉀之後再吃
需要限制的水果 奇異果 香蕉
絕對不能吃的水果 楊桃
提醒你腎臟病人的飲食
要以個人狀況
來調整最安全的做法
我建議你還是
請醫生幫你評估
才不會吃錯
又能夠顧好你的腎臟